There's an islanding
and housing system also,
that's made from a single species of reed
and it's called the Al Tahla
Islands and the mudhif houses.
And you can find them in the
southern wetlands of Iraq
and this incredible waterborne
community and technology
is constructed by the Ma'dan people,
and they construct these
floating islands by fencing off
a section of living reeds
that are called the qasab.
And then upon that living fence,
they stack the dried reeds,
plus mud, plus dried reeds
and mud until they create
this floating platform.
And these mudhif houses and these Al Tahla
floating platforms,
they've actually seen these
depicted in Sumerian Uraq imagery.
So that would estimate this
type of construction technology
at about six and a half
thousand years old.
And the qasab reed is actually integral,
not just to the construction
of these islands
and these beautiful cathedral-like houses,
but it's also integral to
every single aspect of life
for the Ma'dan people.
But also it is food for water buffalo,
it is flour for humans, as
well as creating this material
for these incredible technologies
of the floating islands
and of the arched houses
that are actually constructed
in as little as three days.
And this qasab reed is
so incredibly versatile
that it can be stacked into
creating these islands.
It can be bundled to create
these beautiful columns.
It can be woven to
create floors and walls,
and then it can even be
twisted so that it creates rope
that then binds the buildings
that they're constructing,
which are actually made
without nails or wood or glass.
And these Ma'dan villages
they have been constructed
in the marsh and they stay
afloat for a generation.
So, about 25 years.